venadu copy listen your one-eyed  delirious patient he was telling the  truth there is a way out he died this  morning kind  Vina Vina  listen I'm from Iran and I've come  because I've heard that there are people  here who are immune to the virus oh and  who told you this a dead man I'm sorry  to say might as well keep listening to  him [ __ ] help me won't anybody help  me  [ __ ] wackos there in a damn coat led  by some woman they call the mother they  scribble symbols everywhere do this  [ __ ] rituals I think they even pray  to her I'm looking for anything that  could save my friends if you have  anything we've shown you a path and a  sign mister pray the rest is up to you  and your faith  remain true to the path stranger but it  has only just begun